olá eu vim aqui pra falar sobre a
arquitetura ea sociedade e para isso eu
apresenta a casa da vila matilde
essa casa localizada no bairro normal
num bairro nobre no bairro normal da
cidade de são paulo uma casa de 95
metros quadrados uma casa que chegou até
nós também de uma forma muito com muitos
arquitetos indicação de amigos e
familiares em uma casa que quando dentro
do escritório também foi tratada de
forma equânime forma igual a qualquer
outro projeto ou qualquer outro projeto
nem mais ou menos nessa casa 3
construirá nós procuramos divulgar essa
casa é a partir da divulgação ocorreu
uma repercussão enorme princípio nas
redes sociais e depois numa na mídia
mais ampla
após essa repercussão vieram diversos
prêmios entre eles o de melhor casa do
mundo segundo votação popular do site
mais acessado de fritura do mundo fez
parte da representação brasileira na
principal também bienal de arquitetura
do mundo a bienal de veneza ea pergunta
se fez inevitável porque é porque algo
tão simples tão trivial foi tão
comentado chamou a atenção de tanta
gente
historicamente e predominantemente
arquitetura sempre esteve vinculada e
atuou através de algum tipo de poder
financeiro seja ele da igreja do estado
o privado
as instituições procuram na arquitetura
uma forma de representar seus valores
geralmente belos grandiosos e
arquitetura
pelo seu lado encontra nessas
instituições
um espaço propício para a autoafirmação
e as apresentam belas e grandiosas as
obras de arquitetura
então acabam sendo belas e grandiosas
nesse processo a maior parte da
população as pessoas comuns
cabe a elas um papel o central
fundamental a de espectador
é ela que deve admirar apreciar quando
muitos usufruir de parte daquela
arquitetura
isso transforma então tá maioria das
pessoas e espectadores e como espectador
não é ator
as pessoas não estão acostumadas a
trabalhar a ver e entender a arquitetura
como algo importante na sua vida então
os arquitetos são inacessíveis e
arquitetura também não se preocupa muito
não encontra muito nas pessoas na
maioria da sociedade uma forma adequada
de trabalhar recentemente isso vem
mudando ea gente acredita que a casa
ajuda um pouco nessa discussão então
voltemos a ela
a casa chegou até nós na família nos
contactou não por um desejo um sonho de
uma casa nova
ela nos apresentou um problema que era
um problema sério janelas para o
corredor infiltrações e rachaduras pela
casa toda
dessa forma nós profissionais nós
precisamos atuar da seguinte forma
precisamos diagnosticar avaliar e
apontar caminhos
a forma de exercer esse processo se
aproxima muito de uma atuação de ofício
laboral essa atuação de ofício laboral
como a de um médico de um dentista que
geralmente atua sobre algo imediato o
urgente individual e não como um artista
incompreendido em busca de uma obra
prima é ela
o que proporciona atuações que atendam
às pessoas comuns à maioria dessa
população
gostaria que vocês notassem nessa imagem
a casa vizinha à casa vizinha ao lado é
uma casa também de blocos e que
certamente consumiu mais recursos
a diferença está em diagnóstico
avaliação e desenho num outro exemplo
contrapõe outro projeto nosso com casas
do programa minha casa minha vida
temos sérias restrições com relação ao
programa casa minha casa minha vida mas
não é ele que define o que é a boa marca
de tintura muito menos ele que diz o que
é arquitetura para pobre quem faz isso é
a arquitetura mas é dela também a
capacidade de estar sem respostas
adequadas às diversas demandas
ela tem como ferramenta ao invés de
bisturi zi motorzinhos ela tem o desenho
e o desenho não como fim si próprio
muito menos com o objetivo do espetáculo
o espetáculo transforma arquitetura em
protagonista enquanto nós entendemos a
arquitetura
entendemos que a especificidade da
arquitetura em ser suporte quando nos
tornamos conscientes disso
nos abrimos para uma atuação mais ampla
e direta frente às demandas da sociedade
é muito comum em diversas profissões
especialmente nos considerarmos
especiais muito importantes e relevantes
para os para a construção de um mundo
melhor
acho um pouco exagerado é louvável a
intenção mas não com esses meios com os
meios de que em ver que temos atuado
muito menos sendo este
o objetivo mas como conseqüência de uma
atuação de ofício trabalhada
cotidianamente se baixasse os nossas
expectativas nos abriríamos para
diversas oportunidades e possibilidades
que se tratada de forma consciente e
responsável
aí sim talvez tivéssemos realmente
trabalhando em prol de uma sociedade e
tendo reconhecimento por isso e é por
isso então que essa casa chamou a
atenção de tanta gente podre por estes e
outros motivos mas fundamentalmente por
estes por ela ainda ser uma exceção
nessa relação entre arquitetura ea
sociedade eo nosso trabalho e desejo é
para que ela seja aperfeiçoado e
multiplicada
obrigado
[Aplausos]